CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN AMERICAN
HISTORY THAT THE MEDIA WILL
IGNORE.
AND WHILE THE BIDEN DOJ
CONTINUES TO TARGET DONALD TRUMP
AND HIS ALLIES, THE FBI IS BEING
EXPOSED, SADLY, AS WEAPONIZING
DISINFORMATION TO ILLEGALLY SPY
ON DONALD TRUMP.
WHERE'S MERRICK GARLAND HERE?
WHERE'S THE RAIDS OF THESE
PEOPLE'S HOMES?
HERE WITH REACTION IS TRUMP
ATTORNEY ALINA HABBA ALONG WITH
FOX NEWS LEGAL ANALYST GREG
JARRETT.
GREG WE'LL GET TO YOU IN A
MINUTE YOU WERE DEAD ON ACCURATE
I JUST QUOTED YOU.
ALINA LET ME GET TO YOU AND GET
YOUR REACTION BEING PART OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM.
>> OUTRAGE.
COMPLETE OUTRAGE.
NOT SURPRISED BUT OUTRAGE.
THIS IS NOW THE THIRD PERSON
THAT WE FOUND OUT HAS BEEN
INDICTED AND WAS ON THE PAYROLL
OF THE FBI.
THAT IS -- YOU KNOW, IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE.
I'M THE DOMESTIC TERRORIST
BECAUSE I'M A MAGA REPUBLICAN
BUT THE FBI CAN PAY INFORMANTS
THAT WE NOW KNOW WERE SERVING
DISINFORMATION TO THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN AND TO SERVE THE DNC
AND ALL OF THEM.
BUT WE'RE THE DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS.
EXPLAIN THAT TO ME.
PLUS, ONE THING WE DIDN'T
MENTION, OCTOBER 2020 WAS WHEN
MR. DANCHENKO.
DO YOU KNOW WHEN THAT WAS SEAN?
I KNOW YOU DO BUT PEOPLE
WATCHING, OCTOBER 2020 WAS WHEN
DURHAM WAS APPOINTED SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
THAT'S WHEN THE FBI SAID, OH, WE
BETTER GET YOU OFF PAYROLL NOW
BECAUSE THIS MIGHT NOT LOOK SO
GOOD THAT WE'VE BEEN PAYING YOU
FOR THREE YEARS AND YOU'RE A
PAID INFORMANT.
UNBELIEVABLE.
THERE'S NO WORDS.
>> Sean: GREG, THE OTHER NIGHT,
I MEAN, I JUST QUOTED YOU, THE
DOJ'S CASE COMPLETELY PREDICATED
ON THAT ASSUMPTION THAT THE
DOCUMENTS ARE CLASSIFIED AND NOT
PROTECTED BY PRIVILEGE, AND THE
JUDGE COULDN'T BE ANYMORE STERN
SAYING I'M NOT BUYING THAT
ASSUMPTION OF YOURS.
>> YEAH, THE ALL MIGHTY
IMPERFECTIUS MERRICK GARLAND
SEEMS TO THINK HE'S JUDGE AND
JURY STILL WEARING A BLACK ROBE
ELEVATED BY EVERYBODY ELSE AND
THE JUDGE IN DIPLOMATIC TERMS
SPANKED HIM AND SAID, LOOK,
YOU'RE ARGUING ASSUMPTIONS.
AND YOU HAVEN'T GIVEN THE OTHER
INDIVIDUAL HERE, DONALD TRUMP,
AN OPPORTUNITY TO MACK A COUNTER
ARGUMENT.
YOU'RE ASSUMING THAT THERE'S NO,
SIR EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
YOU'RE ASSUMING THE ALLEGED
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS ARE INDEED
CLASSIFIED WHEN TRUMP SAYS THEY
WERE DECLASSIFIED.
AND SO THE JUDGE SAID IT'S NOT
UP TO YOU.
THESE ARE ISSUES OF LAW AND FACT
THAT ARE TO BE LITIGATED AND
WE'RE FIRST GOING TO HAVE AN
INDEPENDENT NEUTRAL INDIVIDUAL
GO THROUGH ALL OF THESE
DOCUMENTS AND THEN WE'LL
LITIGATE THINGS LIKE CLASSIFIED
AND EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
AND THE JUDGE, YOU KNOW, ALSO,
ONCE AGAIN, IN HER ORDER THIS
EVENING, SORT OF SPANKED MERRICK
GARLAND SAYING, YOU'RE YOUR OWN
WORST ENEMY.
INSTEAD OF SEIZING DOCUMENTS YOU
CLAIM YOU WANT, YOU TOOK
EVERYTHING UNDER THE ROOF.
YOU TOOK THINGS WITH NO
EVIDENTIARY VALUE THAT ARE NOT
ONLY COVERED BY ATTORNEY/CLIENT
PRIVILEGE, YOU TOOK PERSONAL
POSSESSIONS, TAX AND ACCOUNTING
AND MEDICAL RECORDS, AND
CLOTHING, NEWSPAPER ARTICLES,
PHOTOGRAPHS, AND YOU WON'T GIVE
THEM BACK.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, I THINK THIS
JUDGE REALLY SMELLS SOMETHING
FISHY GOING ON WITH MERRICK
GARLAND AND THE DOJ BECAUSE HIS
ARGUMENTS MAKE NO SENSE.
YOU KNOW, HE CLAIMS WE HAVE NO
TIME FOR A SPECIAL MASTER.
EVERYTHING'S URGENT HERE.
WELL, THEN WHY ARE YOU APPEALING
TO THE 11TH CIRCUIT WHICH WILL
ONLY PROLONG THE PROCESS?
WHY ARE YOU SO VIGOROUSLY
OPPOSED TO A SPECIAL MASTER,
SOMEBODY WHO'S NEUTRAL AND
INDEPENDENT THAT WOULD REASSURE
AMERICANS THAT THE PROCESS IS
FAIR AND OBJECTIVE.
AND SO THE JUDGE, I THINK, MADE
THE RIGHT DECISION AND CALLED
OUT MERRICK GARLAND.
>> Sean: ALINA, ARE THE MEDICAL
RECORDS, THE TAX RECORDS,
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE
RECORDS, I KNOW THE PASSPORTS
HAVE BEEN RETURNED.
HAVE THEY BEEN RETURNED, NUMBER
ONE, NUMBER TWO, THE FBI DID ASK
THAT MAR-A-LAGO TURN OFF THE
SECURITY CAMERAS.
YOU DID NOT TURN THEM OFF.
WILL YOU BE RELEASING THOSE
VIDEOS?
>> WE WILL ALWAYS COOPERATE,
SEAN.
WE ALWAYS HAVE, WE ALWAYS WILL.
EVERY INVESTIGATION AS YOU
STATED.
>> Sean: NO I MEAN TO SOMEBODY
LIKE ME.
I'LL TAKE THEM.
I'D LOVE TO HAVE THEM.
HELLO, GUY WORKING IN THE PRESS
HERE.
>> YOU KNOW -- [LAUGHTER].
>> SEAN YOU'LL HAVE ME ON AND
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THEM I DON'T
KNOW IF WE'LL RELEASE THEM.
UNLIKE THESE FEDERAL AGENCIES WE
DON'T LEAK.
WE FOLLOW THE RULES AND I'M
ACTUALLY PROUD OF THE TRUMP TEAM
TODAY, IT WAS A MAJOR WIN, WE
WON ON ALL COUNTS AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT, IT RELAYS FAITH
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY THEY
DELAYED IT UNTIL NOVEMBER 30TH
SO THEIR PLANS OF MESSING AROUND
WITH THE ELECTION YET AGAIN WITH
MIDTERMS GOT A LITTLE SCREWED UP
TODAY.
SORRY ABOUT THAT GUYS.
BUT YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN SO
FAR REACHING.
>> Sean: IS THERE ANYTHING THAT
PROHIBITS YOU FROM RELEASING
THOSE VIDEOTAPES?
>> YOU KNOW WHY WE WOULDN'T,
HONESTLY, SEAN?
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT CARES TOO
MUCH ABOUT THE AGENTS AND THE
ENFORCEMENT THAT WERE JUST DOING
THEIR JOB.
>> Sean: YOU COULD PIXEL OUT
THEIR FACES FFRJTS YEA
.
>> YEAH, WELL, MAYBE THEN.
THIS WASN'T MY CASE IF IT WAS I
WOULD BE RIGHT THERE WITH YOU.
>> Sean: HE'S HAVING A BAD HAIR
DAY WE